we've seen some awful images uh
apartment blocks hit civilians covered
in blood
are we doing enough to help ukraine i've
just come off the phone again to
president vladimir zelinski of ukraine
and let's be in no doubt things are not
going all the way of president putin
very far from it the ukrainians are
fighting heroically
and
in some places with great success as as
many of us thought they would because
they're a great country in a very brave
country but as you as you rightly point
out there are some terrible atrocities
being committed and there will be some
very grim days ahead for ukraine we've
got to do everything we can to change
the the heavy odds that ukraine faces
and
and to help them and so that's why we're
sending
humanitarian supplies we're sending
financial supplies and military supplies
as well i think it's uh very important
we do that the uk was the first european
country to send military aid
to ukraine
last night
many other countries joined in sending
and pledging to send military assistance
you'll start to see that that grow what
we need to do now
and you ask should we do more the answer
is yes and we need to make sure that we
apply those much tougher economic
sanctions including swift and what's
starting to happen
is that
the the horror of what is unfolding in
ukraine is becoming clear to western
audiences and that is in turn putting
huge pressure on western politicians
we're good we've got to act uh together
and we've got to do more why aren't we
taking refugees like some other
countries of course we're going to take
uh refugees this country's had a
historic and proud role in
in taking refugees from uh all conflicts
and if you think what we did in uh in
afghanistan for instance the uk was was
way out in front i'm aware that there's
some fake news on the internet about
that and i really want to knock that on
the head the uk is way out in front in
our willingness to help with refugees
we've sent a thousand troops to uh to
the the theater uh to be ready to help
with the influx and of course we will
help people uh fleeing in fear of their
lives do you think diplomacy is dead now
um you know should we face facts that
all the diplomacy that was taken
that was done by europe seemingly has
had little effect i think we have to
face the hideous reality that the
diplomacy as far as president putin was
concerned was a charade he never really
intended
to alter his course you read the article
that he wrote many months ago it was
clear that he's attached to a weird
semi-mystical view of ukraine as part of
of russia and that is a view that the
ukrainian people fervently passionately
reject and they're showing that they
will fight to reject it our job now is
to help them to help change the very
heavy odds that they face and that's why
we're sending the support that we are
you mentioned swift do we need to do
more to push other countries to ban
russia from the swift banking system i
think that what you've seen just today
is more countries joining the call of
the uk to use swift swift is the
mechanism that stops people making
payments uh to vladimir putin's russia
it's incredibly important for tightening
the the the ligature the economic
ligature around the putin regime and
today you've seen more and more
countries france and others coming
forward to say that they will not block
a a banning a boycott of swift let me
ask you about sporting connections now
poland and sweden's football teams are
refusing to play russia in the world cup
playoffs should we be breaking off our
sporting connections i think it's
inconceivable to imagine that uh i mean
it's a sad thing because i don't think
we've had a situation like this for a
very very long time but it's
inconceivable to me to imagine that
normal sporting relations uh with
putin's russia can continue
and is it frustrating that some
countries like china abstained rather
than voting to condemn this illegal
invasion at the u.n security council i
think what you're seeing today
and over the last uh of the last few
hours is a sense around the world that
this is a horror that they simply hadn't
expected and i think that feeling is
strong uh and growing not just in in
countries that have uh in the middle
ground but in russia itself you're
starting to see that feeling that this
is something unconscionable so i think
that in countries that have been
apathetic on this issue so far a sense
of of outrage and disgust is growing at
what the putin the putin regime is doing
in ukraine in the meantime the uk is
going to do everything we can to help
and support our friends in ukraine